you do these shows with with Steve
Martin yes and they're fantastic you two
did it you did conan joined us in las
vegas last spring that was one of them
that was one of the thrills of my life
you were so know these two guys who I
idolized growing up because I'm much
younger and in fact you know we have two
titles we have a show yeah
one is an evening you'll forget for the
rest of your life but the other ones do
you want to call it seem to darkest see
them before they're dead but I have to
see it so you've not seen these guys
together on stage it is electric it's
magnified it's just fantastic one of my
favorite shows that I've ever seen you
guys working together so funny and I'm
just curious what's it like cuz you know
Steve Martin can be a bit of an enigma
is he's a little hard to get to know
what's your take on Steve what's it like
working with him well it's it's I've
said it before and I've said I'll say it
again cuz it's in the act now working
with Steve is very much like the film
deliverance it's it's all fun and games
until the banjos come on
[Applause]
now I adore him he's so hilarious he's
so funny I once said to him Steve what
would you be doing if you weren't a
talented comedic actor and he said
probably what you're doing now you guys
are going on the road you have other
like 38 40 cities right in the course of
2017 if you get a chance run don't walk
I'm serious
see these two guys on stage I don't
remember and you know what I brought
I brought my head writer with me and he
was backstage crying oh man just I mean
we were both laughing you already did
kill them then you must admit you you
you rose to the occasion very hot you
know I've just been used to hearing a
lot of laughs for a long time so
[Laughter]
I guess that's I guess that's what I do
you know yeah buddy brought a writer Oh
in a film piece and a laugh track right
that'd be great if I'd come out with a
laugh oh man that would make it easy
ladies and gentlemen there's no one in
the world funnier than Martin Short
[Applause]
[Music]
you